if somebody is walking down the street
looking in their phone
[Applause]
[Music]
because they'll see the hand coming
first like what
okay for two games I like Gucci these
are all things I really enjoy so there's
a lot of opportunity for that here in
this head but this product side of the
computer inside every time I come here
I'm going to be overly friendly just to
see nothing
so really enthusiastic
so couple years ago I'll say here my
three favorite things we try to make
people uncomfortable or get older
couple years ago I decided I started
really friend a close
we do this come this way
my sex work
[Music]
so soon as he got back there and I stood
I wasn't in this personal space but I
was I could see the [ __ ] mind
so I've been here we've also made this
go it's right I stood right here
[Applause]
I got you three boys you pitch your
weakness
father might have done something else
you know but I see they let her go
I realize right now this beautys he's
dead so let's go to 17 44 29 and so that
it's just be inhibited in our disgusting
mr. tak and showing us is he
[Applause]
[ __ ]
a little favorite all-time all-time last
you would like I mentioned walking down
the street in university especially
between five and seven o'clock of the
week there is like an Olympic sport you
you you have to know and you can tell
who that time right you can tell you
know people just stop
those are the people hi I'm surprised
doing here
tourists I miss bouquets
people like you ask them what do you
want to ask about the people whose
family
[Music]
the serious convenience it was packed
six o'clock and fry and I started
walking on the street
like I had never seen a [ __ ] building
right and I just hear from the side so
I'm leaning against the building I hear
something